if you and i were able to go into skyrim
right and walk around
and live together would we make love no
no no man don't go there okay no no no
because we like girls man
the following is a conversation with
bobby lee a stand-up comedian and
podcaster and one of the funniest humans
on the planet and just someone who
brings joy to my heart with a mix of
non-sequitur absurdity darkness
and the singing voice of an angel in all
seriousness bobby's just a beautiful
human being i've been a fan of his for
20 years since his time on mad tv to
today with his podcast tiger belly that
he does
with his other half the love of his life
kalyala and the podcast bad friends that
he does with andrew centino
this is a lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's bobby lee
i've been a fan of yours for many many
years i think you're one of the funniest
people in the world
i've been a fan since my tv days 20
years ago
to today with uh with tiger belly so
given that given your status as a
world-class comedian
how did it feel that you were not
invited to andrew schultz's wedding and
i was
well you were there yeah i was there
i was the least funny person there yeah
and the whole time i was thinking
isn't that funny that bobby lee's not
here
yeah um
all my life i always felt like people
didn't like me and they didn't want to
invite me to things you know i mean i
think that's fundamentally
the reason why i do what i do
so it really did hurt a lot
and um i had resentments i did some uh
revenge fantasies
about how i'm gonna get revenge on him
and stuff yeah and him specifically him
specifically okay like have a big
wedding invite everyone
you know i mean accept him stuff like
that yeah and then just write him a
letter like see that's how it feels or
whatever
but instead of that i'm because i'm in
therapy and stuff i'm just kind of like
trying to let it go what did you do
there this right here why'd you do that
i forgot to start the timer and now it's
going to start over yeah let's do this
let's do it again
take two no uh you still feel like an
outsider you're exceptionally successful
me domain you still feel yeah you know
i'm doing a netflix show tonight with
andrew santino at the comedy store and
this nap but like last night you know i
just felt like i wasn't a part of
in fact on stage i go i even mentioned
that i go netflix
they don't like me you know i mean and i
just say things like that um they're not
true
and this is something that i want to
correct with myself because i have this
internal dialogue that's based
on just the past and 99 of the things
that go on in my mind aren't true and
i'm just at a point in my life where i'm
just don't want to start i won't start i
don't want to live like that anymore
really because i'm the same way i'm
deeply self-critical all the time yeah
and um that's kind of an engine that
drives you to to do stuff
yeah but it doesn't give you the kind of
freedom
that i would like don't you want to be
truly free
free from your mind
free from negative thoughts
no i i'm free part of the day when some
of the day i spend being extremely
self-critical and that drives you
because i'm afraid i'll become ultra
lazy otherwise
because i love life i love being
comfortable i love just relaxing i need
very few things in life and so i'm
afraid i'll just get like super lazy oh
are you a minimalist yeah so if i went
to your house in austin do you have a
couch
i recently got this is the first college
i've gotten
ever
because the guests were complaining
because i also record uh the podcast
there the guests are complaining there's
nowhere to sit i have no chairs no couch
i sleep on the floor like a mattress is
on the floor
um
not out of principle i think out of some
kind of uh
minimalist momentum minimal smoke so
we're the opposite in that way then oh
so you like stuff
i'm not a hoarder but because i can
throw things away but i have a shopping
addiction i think
like when i'm on the road like i was in
oklahoma for two weeks
i just i bought a bunch of stuff you
know what i mean and then
oh my god i went to todd snyder and i
bought um i've got these shoes
you know
because you know but you're wearing them
so they're they're actually you're using
them and they're giving value to your
life that's awesome yeah but this is the
last day i'm gonna wear these this is
one time
this is like a wedding but yeah it's a
red carpet dress who's a designer do you
know i don't know anything what are you
wearing bobby i don't know what i'm
wearing but i because i'm on a native
show called reservation dogs right i
just want to get into the spirit of
things that's your
yeah this is because if i was ever like
native and i was in a tribe back in the
day you know what i mean i would have
been a gatherer
um yeah i'm not a hunter no i'm i'm
gonna weave baskets with the ladies yeah
i want to pick berries with the ladies
you wouldn't be the chieftain no no and
i would make after the hunt i would
probably make some let some of the guys
make love to me
oh
yeah because i'm gay just because you
know yeah yeah
yeah yeah
there's a power hierarchy you got to
know your place in the hierarchy yeah
you're alpha male then
i don't even know what that means joe
rogan
joe rogan is the definition of alphabet
to me yeah if i if there was a picture
of alpha male in the dictionary
it would be joe rogan yeah yeah
yeah
so you hoard stuff okay yeah yeah but
you can throw on when was the last time
let me call you out on that when's the
last time you threw away something
that's actually valuable
valuable like something valuable to you
or valuable in general most things that
i buy aren't valuable to me there are
things that are valuable to me that are
like keepsakes from my family and stuff
that i will keep forever so i like in
terms of like an old photo of my father
or whatnot so those kind of things i
keep but um
when it comes to like you know
aviator nation sweats like if some of
like somebody came into my house and
goes hey can i have six of those
sweatshirts or whatever i'd be like yeah
go take it okay my brother's come over
to my house and just done a clearance
you know i mean like i'm going to take
this this this i generally
really don't have a problem with so the
self-critical voice is serving no
purpose
in terms of because you're pretty you
know i've i'm a fan of yours so you're
known to be a little bit lazy sometimes
100 lazy yeah yeah so the self-critical
voice don't you think that it's
serving a purpose and fighting off the
laziness
beating off the laziness
the self-critical voice that i have
i've been able to come compartment la
how do you say compartment yeah however
you say
you're free yeah yeah
put it in a compartment yeah right and
um i'm able to like um
i'm a good avoider i'm good at avoidance
so for instance
right now um to avoid i i've been
playing stardew valley
you know what that is no
phone game or no it's a um you can play
it on your switch but it's on the xbox
and it's a farming simulation game and
so i like to farm you know i mean and so
and playing video games and doing stuff
like that distracts me from
giving me what really is going on okay
you've mentioned elsewhere in terms of
video games elder scrolls did you play
that yeah of course it's probably my
favorite game if i could live in a world
you played morrowind and skyrim i played
oblivion oblivion i played a little bit
of morrowind but i didn't like the
graphics back then but i really played
the can i swear on this podcast yeah i
played the [ __ ] out of um oblivion and
skyrim like
eight characters played it all the way
through i have to do all the quests that
type of thing what's your favorite thing
about those games
um why did you spend so much time in
that world because i i like games that
you can grind
what do you mean by grind so like
stardew valley for instance right
there's a lot of like to the farm that's
farming right okay it's the same thing
as skyrim the reason why i like it is
that there's a lot of like
i have to collect a lot of these things
you know i mean i have to just
constantly pick things up you know i
mean yeah like for instance in skyrim
there's a mushroom called blister wart
mushroom that you can pick and then you
can make it into some sort of formula
right yeah potion yeah that's right yep
so i would spend like
literally human 12 hour days
just going to every cave and picking up
as much blister wart as i could like
that kind of grinding you know what i
mean yeah yeah so you're actually the
randomly generated quests that gives you
yeah it's designed for people like you
yeah you don't get bored that's the
that's the fun yes that's the fun for me
okay yeah there's always something to do
and i find like when when you play a
game that's linear like
there's certain games where you have to
go this way right i don't like games
like that yeah i like open world games
where i can make choices and i can grind
if i want yeah yeah would you stay in
that world if you could live in that
world
in the in the elder scrolls world that's
how i feel
in reality or become like a
animated thing in there oh no say like
virtual reality we're moving towards
that direction oh yeah if you look at
skyrim you mentioned graphics it's
become
it's starting to get realistic yeah like
i i i'll sometimes just walk around i
mean it's been a while but i'll just
walk around and skyrim yeah you can uh
there's code you can turn off enemies
and you just walk around really you can
just listen to music and just walk
around
that's what you did yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would do that wouldn't you do that
would you do it with me
you sure we would have a house together
oh i mean live i thought walk around no
no no no if you and i were able to go
into skyrim right and walk around
and live together would we make love no
no no man don't go there okay no no no
because we like girls man
that's right it's not gay well you told
me it's not gay yeah yeah yeah all right
so you and i would yeah i would hunt you
would gather
but in that world there's no hunting
yeah but there is hunting i would do we
have because we don't have to find our
bandits we have to fight i'm not gonna
gather a bandit i'm gonna hunt them but
i think it's all about the potion you
don't need the bandits okay well we
could do this we could you could be the
guy that like defends our place yeah
right i'll gather all the um blister
wart all the white caps all the
mushrooms i'll i'll get all the food
yeah i mean i'll go to white run
remember white run
right or winter hold and i'll i'll do
all the like quests that have nothing to
do with you know what i mean so no
dragons though no no dragons but we
would have a banquet would invite the
dark dark brotherhood yeah right the
fighters guild we definitely invite them
mages guilds we'd invite them are you a
thief kind of guy i'm a thief guy yeah
i'm a i'm for life yeah i'm a thief guy
for life and you still wouldn't invite
andrew schultz to that no no no but what
a piece of [ __ ] though huh because let
me just say something okay i just want
to get back to that okay okay sure so i
met him
at the montreal comedy festival and him
and i
are kindred
souls we really connected yeah
and he did my podcast he's done it
several times done his we've we've like
communicated on the phone this and that
and to me and then he invites whitney
cummings which whitney is a good friend
of mine but what i'm saying is is that i
know
andrew as well as whitney knows them i
don't think that whitney knows them more
than i do
right what if it was a competition like
it was a tie
you know and like nba like a bobby lee
versus whitney yeah what what in what
way do you think she's better and what
way do you think you're better
i think it's all about gender optics
okay right so there's a comedian
he has all these alpha males coming and
he's like all right i can i have one
more seat left yeah whitney or bobby but
bobby's although i don't think there was
a lot of koreans there so he could have
used that card this is true right but i
think he went for you know whitney's a
woman that's better for optics okay so
she was a diversity hire for the wedding
yeah
i see it was it was pretty fun it was
pretty i have to say i don't
it was joe rogan yeah i know his wife i
get it yeah and then uh whitney are
those comedians that were there
i spent the whole time talking to jose i
i think no i don't think there was that
many comedians so i'm kind of joking
about
it was pretty pretty small wedding yeah
what do you talk to joe about
first of all we're both grapplers so
we're talking a lot about jiu jitsu we
talk a lot about i'm a grappler are you
i was on the wrestling team in high
school yeah i know i know this is a
grappler that to you that if i don't
know jiu-jitsu is there only one kind of
grappling that you like yeah there's
levels to this game i think oh i just
talked no no there's nothing more yeah
there's no that's a surprising fact that
you've dropped that it almost feels like
a lie because you've said that before
that you were a wrestler in yeah in high
school doesn't make sense well it's
funny that you say that because
and i'm going to call it a little
controversy here yeah right but joe
rogan yes one time came to when he lived
in l.a this is years ago he said you're
a liar you've never grappled yep and i
go yes i did you're a [ __ ] liar no
you didn't and at that time i didn't
have any photos to prove it
but if you look at my instagram i have
photos
of you as a young man dressed in a
singlet or what on the wrestling team
if you go to the
[ __ ] sorry if you go to my i'm sorry
if you go to my [ __ ]
high school yep you're right i was on
the wrestling team for three years i'm
not gonna go to your high school so is
there actual photo evidence of you yeah
you know what you're you're being like
rogan right now and i you know me it
really is how do we know it's not
photoshopped oh you can you will you be
the judge then dude
okay so this is my brother and me
in high school on the wrestling team
which oh it's you're uh yeah i'm the
bottom that's my brother to the left i
mean yeah to your right oh handsome yeah
i'm not as five yeah
uh how much you weigh wow at the time i
weighed um i was on the 105 weight
category yeah yeah um but so i was also
on the tennis team what people don't
realize is that i'm very athletic okay
yeah yeah and i resent the fact that
people that think that i'm not because
i'm doughy you're an athlete so uh which
is very surprising to me why that uh so
i was invited to the wedding yeah yeah
i've also been on joe rogan's podcast
he's a big fan of yours i know i i love
joe no joe when joe's and i see to the
weehawkest now we talked i just talked
to him today i said i'm talking to you
this is hilarious so why oh you hug him
you just never
it just hasn't worked out like i don't
like i don't want to go like
hey um
if because i don't want the rejection so
it's like if i go right hey
can i do it and he goes uh i don't know
man i'm busy man we got i got a lot i
mean maybe later you know i don't want
that
so if you know
if
if he said hey are you available
thursday this date fly out do my podcast
i would 100 do it and that hasn't
happened yet
so interesting
why is it interesting i don't know
because you're like i said you're one of
the funniest people in the world that'd
be a great conversation it's just funny
it hasn't happened yet well it's like
this conversation it's like i just
learned how to tell time
yeah
not like i know how to write digital you
showed up on time today no digital i
know how to write digital obviously but
in terms of the hand clock yeah i just
learned that six months ago
uh how to operate a hand clock to read a
can clock hand clock yeah okay not that
i i obviously i'll be able to absorb the
information i just i'm one of those guys
that just refused to learn things if i
just
what did you think it was before
i would look at it and i would try to
sometimes like if i was at a train
station yeah
and i would look at those old clogs yeah
i would look at it and try to guess and
i'd kind of go
i think this is the way you know what i
mean but like not fully
you know i mean really grass so the way
ancient people looked up at the sun to
try to tell time you looked at a clock
to try to tell time right like for
instance like we don't look at the sun
right so to me it was an obsolete
information to me
because of the digital you already had
digital yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
that's somehow comparable to you going
on the joe rogan and you because it's
like i don't know much about
podcasting not podcasting i can but in
terms of like the singularity and all
that stuff like i i know what it is you
know i mean when machines gonna be have
consciousness
when is that gonna happen
soon are you afraid of robots see if you
were in austin i would show you some
robots oh i'd love to are you afraid of
robots no i love it you love robots oh
yeah yeah in fact i have this
i think to me unless they become hostile
and it becomes like the terminator which
i think could happen right
there'd be a skynet we have to bring it
down whatever but there's definitely
going to be autonomous weapons systems
so a lot of the robotics research is
being conducted funded by
the military
wow
you know the military-industrial complex
i know what that is yes yeah so the the
a lot of the cutting-edge research is
done
is funded by
uh dod department of defense darpa and
so on so a lot of the robots will be
used in war but hopefully not
most of consumer robotics will be in the
home i'm just trying to terrify you no
no but could i ask you this though sure
what you're saying to me
is is that as a layperson
is that in my lifetime
that
machines will have consciousness
oh that i don't know computers i'm one
of the people with depending here you
live dangerously so i don't know how
long you're going to live
so let's let's put
but i believe that consciousness yes
could be engineered in the machine
uh or at least we can have machines that
are human-like
and we believe they have consciousness
can i ask you one last question about it
yes okay
but we'll take one more will they have
the smoothness of skin and will they
look realistic
see i'm one of those people that
believes that visual appearance isn't
the magic
so if you close your if you're blind you
can still have a connection with a
person
people can fall in love with each other
through just letters
so yeah i know you're mocking me with
your entire energy but yes um yes i
believe that part two you're talking
about sex spots is what you're probably
getting okay intimacy why would you just
friends friends but you wanted friends
you want to feel the smoothness yeah
like a guy like you know just go what's
up dude and just just just hug and yeah
like on both cheeks kind of thing i get
what you're saying though right
obviously there's no soul right you know
i mean and i'm just curious to see
have you you're right i was going with
sex bots but yeah
have you seen whitney uh cummings's
robot yeah i've seen it okay yeah how
did that make you feel
she's a beautiful girl i just don't find
her attractive the robot or wouldn't he
i find the robot way more attractive
yeah if i had the choice robot so you
were turned on by the robot see i was
surprised
by the very thing you're saying which is
the realism of the skit like it was
quite they did a really good job on that
robot oh they did the the life when when
it's animated the life is not quite
there
you can tell it's a robot but just
sitting there
still
it has a lot of human like elements the
texture i don't know yeah yeah it's
quite fast they're getting there they're
getting there yeah yeah but the funny
thing about sex robots is most people
that get sex robots
they don't get it for the sex they get
it for like intimacy
like um not not sexual intimacy but like
just somebody being there
it's the
emotional connection not the sexual yeah
i mean i you know i i saw a long time
ago a um
a documentary about real dolls and
people marrying them yeah yeah and
what i was fascinated about is the
cuddling
you know i mean and then watching tv
together
and stuff like that which i find
you know
i've just been able to
find human girlfriends and stuff
so that's really impressive that's one
of the reasons thanks man yeah thanks
hey speaking of human girlfriends yeah
um i'd love your advice in this
direction
but you're you have an amazing
relationship with uh kalila yeah uh so
you two are very different so you host
the tiger by the podcast together but
there's there's real love there there's
a there's a real connection
what do you um what do you love most
about kalyala
let's talk about love bobby lee yeah
yeah i mean that's a really pretty deep
i've never really gone down this path um
we're gonna walk down that path together
holding hands
it's one of those things where
the first time i met her
it was almost as if i had known her all
my life it was really weird you know i
mean there was a
a trust there you know i mean that was
just fundamentally there
that i could trust her
and that i could you know
when i look in the mirror
and i see all my character defects and
stuff
though a lot of those things aren't
necessarily things i want to share with
people because i don't want to be judged
or ridiculed
but with her
i felt comfortable showing those things
and
i think she feels the same way about her
and then secondly she's funny
i mean she made me laugh and and she's
hot
it's it's all you know i mean the
perfect it was like a perfect
combination of things you know i mean
she
one night we were in bed and i forgot
what the joke was but she really made me
laugh one night it was she was living in
an apartment in long beach and i cackled
you know i mean and generally
women don't make i mean not women i'm
dating comics do
um don't make me cackle in that way
and then um thirdly she has um
she's partly asian
so it's like
you know one time i dated a white girl
yeah and i invited her to korea town are
you about to be a racist a little bit
okay yeah yeah
and
what i love about asian girls
is
they'll eat something first and ask what
it is after
but white girls ask what it is before
what is this
right
but clyde was like would eat the eyeball
eat everything go what did i just eat i
like that
you know what i mean
so it's like and it reminds me of my mom
in that way in terms of like my mom
growing up just to
scare us and freak us out we'd have a
fish and she would eat the eyeball first
to see a squirm and as a kid that you
thought was gross and weird and this and
that but it's like
you know when kalila does it it just
kind of like i don't just
make feet makes makes me feel like at
home yeah in a weird way i don't know
it's a
it's a little act of fearlessness i like
that yeah just put in your mouth and
figure it out
yeah that's what i like
and at the end of the day she also
out of all my girlfriends and uh this is
gonna sound
not strange but um hard to admit but
my career when i met kalila was in the
[ __ ] box
i could not get anything going and um
this is at the time where
ken jong who's a very good friend of
mine very talented was getting
everything
and i just remember going i can't even
get an audition like i can't i would go
on the road
lex and i would fill half the room
i just couldn't sell tickets and
when i met her i was just kind of like
maybe this is the i had to find love and
open up my
world in that way
and
she was the first girlfriend that i ever
had that
looked at me and saw the potential
and she said no this is not doesn't feel
right you're so funny
and you're so relevant to me
and this is what we're gonna do
and so
she started tiger belly
you know and then um
obviously i had the skill set to do it
um
but once tiger belly happened and then
andrew was like let's do bad friends and
then
now
things are great you know my career is
i'm too busy almost in a weird way you
know
and i feel like she had a lot to do with
like for instance
before i met her even if i would get an
audition i wouldn't go
because i just wouldn't get it in my
head i was like i'm not gonna get this
i've gone on a thousand of these and
they just never hire me but she was so i
just didn't go on on them for years
and then she was the first girlfriend
that said no
i don't care if you don't get it right i
just want you to be a [ __ ]
and i want you to walk through fear
and so she would drag me to these
[ __ ] things and i
for some reason would book them
you know what i mean so
you know in that way you saw the
potential of what you could be but she
loved you for who you are already yes
but also loved you for the potential
that you could become
yeah and i'm lucky in that way you know
so on day one you could show her you
said you could show her your flaws to
her like you felt like you could be
fragile with her well i accidentally
farted yeah or day one on day one yeah
you know because i just i'm a fart
machine yeah and i have loose cheeks
yeah
i like how you would for the listeners
he just swinged at me yeah
i have loose cheeks and um but not in a
gay way not in a gateway no and i um i
was wearing a couch and were talking and
i kind of adjusted my body i ripped one
by accident
and she laughed you know i mean it
wasn't embarrassing you know and um
i also have a little penis
i have a little penis and it's all
relative yes it's for little
but relative to an elephant
everybody's penis is little yeah but i'm
not an elephant i'm a human you know i
mean so relatively human it's very small
and so when she saw it you know i mean i
thought she was gonna bark at it yeah
right and she looked at it as if it was
like an orphan
like
you know like i wanna
you know it's a lost child and i wanna
you know you know take care of it yep
yeah cradle it cradle yeah
well you man you you haven't met anybody
like that
uh never met a girl never seen one of
them
i hear they're nice
when are the two you get married
we don't know yet
yeah is that something you would like
yeah um this comes up sometimes you know
we're in couples counseling we're
dealing we're working on some issues
that we have sure every relationship
even my friendships have issues
and so we're working through some issues
and once we get to the end of it we'll
figure it out would you like to be a
father one day
this is kind of couples counseling
you know yeah i do
i do because i i feel like um
you know before i was very childlike you
know i play a lot of video games i'm
irresponsible i'm lazy this and that
right but you know
to be honest with you lex in the last
six months i've really have come through
some breakthroughs
and um i'm in therapy and i'm doing a
lot of things and really self-analyzing
myself and my behaviors
and what i want my desires and i think
ultimately yes i really do
because it's a life experience that um
you know i don't want to be
an old man looking back and going
it's something that i've always was
interested in and i think it's based on
fear because i don't want to um
scar my
child the way my parents carried me
but at the same time
my parents didn't do
the work on themselves like i am
and they were never about
self-improvement they were just about
they were immigrants you know and they
wanted to put food on the table and um
after that they just went about their
business and i'm not like that i would
never be violent toward my kids like my
parents were
my dad was very physically abusive you
know
there was a lot of trauma and stuff and
so um
you know as a kid i i thought you know i
just would never put my kid through this
so that's why i never wanted it but
i would completely do it differently you
know um
even yelling and and those kind of
things i would be very mindful about
those things and i think that i have
certain things you know i'm not a
sciency guy like you but there are thing
life things that i've learned over the
years that i could teach a child
you know about living in the moment or
walking through fear or you know
things that you know things will pass
and just different things you know that
i could i would be a good listener and
um
yeah i would like to
do that
so your uh your dad died in
august of 2019. wow
yeah
he did your research
uh yeah it's on your wikipedia
so you said some of it was rough but
what's your fondest memory of your dad
what those memories happened later in
life
um as a child my fondest memory was
my mom because he never spent time with
us so um my mom
made him
take me out one day
and he took me to a park
like he doesn't there was no baseball
glove or baseball or anything like that
and we sat on a park bench
right
and we just sat there for hours
we didn't talk because he didn't know
english that well they didn't know
korean
so it's just very you know basic you
know information being you know i mean
uh how are you
this is how we go how are you
doing yeah i'm okay you know
good good good
that type of thing yeah for a long time
for a long time and then
but the day turned bad because i forgot
my jacket there
and he yelled at me
there was a bit of a piece together at
that time yeah that was peace but then
what happened was
later in life when i got mad tv
and i was doing
you know in my early years you know i
booked a couple of things like
in 2000 i did the tonight show on leno
and then i did um i got mad tv in 2000
and um wow that was over 20 years ago
and um
that's when they my parents kind of went
huh
you know
because obviously you know
there's some nepotism in hollywood right
but in my case my parents were
straight-up immigrants i had no
connections to hollywood and i came up
here poor
you know with no connections
and i built
it you know i mean through the years you
know and in in that way
i'm very proud of myself because i went
through a lot of [ __ ] hell
and sadness and desperation and all that
stuff and i persevered and i did all
that [ __ ] on my own man i i booked the
tonight show on my own i got mad tv on
my own and when i did those things my
parents were very
proud
but before that did they doubt you oh
yeah
you you're not you're not funny
you you
you never
make me laugh yeah right and that kind
of stuff yeah you're never gonna make it
you know i mean you're going to be poor
all your life you know that kind of
stuff but mad tv he was proud
he died well you know every because it
was a weekly show so on saturday nights
they would watch it and i would yeah and
i would i would play
characters that they would understand
like i did kim jong il at the time yeah
right so they loved that right they
loved you know the things that i would
do the physical comedy yeah and they
couldn't believe in their mind you know
ima imagine your parents from korea
coming here
you know not knowing the language having
a child here right
and in their minds that was never like
an option
right and so when they see their kid i
guess on tv
especially there was no internet too at
the time
the internet had just started
so
to them they were like this is a miracle
in fact when i did the tonight show my
dad called me the next day and asked me
hum
he literally asked me this he goes
how much
did you pay them to do it
he thought that i had saved all my money
like like he thought that like tom
cruise goes up there and goes here's a
grand thanks for having me on like you
know i mean no i go no they asked me
like so all the conceptually
they were just shocked by it so when i
got it and then they were watching me
weekly
mad tv
the producer was like hey have your dad
on
so my dad did
two or three sketches
on television so and that so those
memories i also did a pilot for comedy
central and he was on my pilot
uh pilot for like a show yeah so i did
got picked up but he was on the pilot he
was in the show yeah he was in the pilot
he was on that tv too on television
interesting yeah oh wow okay yeah yeah
so it's like he
he would get residual checks yeah you
know
you know just change everything those uh
nepotism in reverse yeah yeah it was
really nepotism in reverse and so he
in those those memories are very i have
very fond memories because he had
changed as well he was
no longer that violent kind of a guy he
had softened a lot you know i mean but
um
when he died
is when those issues came up you know
like a freight train the bad stuff oh
yeah
and i didn't know what was going on i
was it was really hard
you miss him
yeah
how often do you think about them
every day obviously a lot of it's
regrets you know i mean
like what kind of regrets not having
said something or
not having had a conversation
it's not regrets because even if you
were still alive they're just things
that are impossibilities because of his
culture
and the way he was raised but my regret
in life will always be
um having those types of even because i
tried i was with my mom
um a couple of months ago
and um
i i looked at her
i had tears in my eyes we're at a
starbucks i go mom i just want to let
you know that i'm so sorry
that you
lived in that house and my dad you know
and dad hit you and you survived you
stayed in the marriage because of us
right
and you know what the response was
let's go to buka the peppa
she wanted italian food
like it was
it's like there was no there was nothing
there right
and so my regret is is that you know
that they
just wouldn't they'll never be able to
even grasp the concept of that kind of
communication you know what i mean and
i'll never have it um
so that's sad to me you know but there's
nothing i can do about it yeah that
callus that comes with an immigrant
mentality you don't even that emotional
connection is not even there i've had
my grandmother yeah she there's
something called honda more which is uh
starvation in ukraine in the 1930s
that you had to live through she lived
through world war ii and there's nothing
like the only way you survive that is
the callous you bring yeah you can't
talk with people that fought in
in major wars they can't
they can't yeah i can't talk about it my
mom when she was 12 years old she walked
her little sister my aunt to school
right
she forgot a book so my mom goes to my
little sister my aunt stay here i'm
gonna get my book she ran up she came
back while she was gone a military truck
ran over
my aunt and my mom discovered her body
split in half in trails the whole thing
and my mom and my uncles had to go and
get rice bags to pick up her you know i
mean
and then bury her my aunt you know when
you live through something like that and
also the guilt
because my mom believes deep down that
if she didn't forget that book
that her my aunt would still be alive
right so she carries all this guilt and
this and to survive all that trauma you
have to build a callus
back then they didn't have emdr and
therapists and psychologists and any of
that right so they had to survive so
that's who she is and it's sad to me
that you know i mean
that it'll forever she'll forever live
in that torment
[Laughter]
um boy
what about your own
what's uh
what's been
the darkest place you've ever gone in
your mind
you wrote that down in my mind in your
mind do you ever consider suicide
i didn't write that okay have you
considered it
in the distance yeah i've distantly
thought about it um
you know
about four months ago
i was in a really bad place
i was naked
in a hotel room
in arizona i hadn't eaten
in like almost a week i hadn't slept in
over a week i haven't sl you know
and i thought i was dying i i was
coughing up blood
and um i
was waiting to go into a
outpatient
psychologist place you know i mean in
arizona i literally thought i was dying
so recently i i was in a very dark place
how much was that connected to losing
your father how much was that connected
to uh
rehab and that kind of stuff
alcohol drugs all the same thing dude
it's all the same thing man it's it's um
it's all from my childhood right the
reason why i do stand up is because of
my childhood
the hating yourself or like being
self-critical that has to do with your
childhood yes so the drugs and drinking
is childhood childhood it's all about
survival and protecting your heart
you know and there are way there are
ways that i did that as a kid like um
using
humor as a defense mechanism um
and also avoidance of all emotions you
know i mean because i just want to feel
and i'm a the reason why comedy is so
good
the reason why i was able to survive in
comedy is because
i can withstand
a lot of [ __ ] and pain
you know i mean like physic like
physical emotional spiritual pain
i'm i can absorb it right but now what's
happened
you know later in life
is i'm unwilling to do that
i'm unwilling to absorb it i'm unwilling
to carry this weight around with me and
um
it'll kill me so i am doing everything i
can
to free myself of all this baggage okay
so how
you're naked in arizona in a hotel room
face down or face up or on the side or
what's your favorite uh when you go to a
dark place
on the floor on the bed or so what
happened
shower a fetal position okay
i don't lay on my stomach that's weird
like like i'm not doing like a downward
dog or yoga position or anything like
that no i'm like
i'm on the bed on the floor no what
happened was
so i had to relapse so i was doing
drinking
all night long what was the first
relapse what what is the thing the first
thing you did just drank what wine
no i took an edible
yeah and that opened the door to
drinking
yeah
and the combination is not good for me
um
and i do the
excess of the amount isn't that good for
me i just can't stop and i do it 24
hours a day are you alone
well no i was living with kalila no i
mean at that moment when you do the
edibles i was alone no i took a flight
because i was shooting
magnum i'm on a show called magnum pi
so i was flying to hawaii
so i bought
edibles and then on right before i was
gonna get on the plane i looked at my
girlfriend and said i'm gonna relapse
i'll see you i know
so i got on the plane i took it
and then
literally the last the next
three months were like a blur
why'd you know what what will give you
the sense that you're going to relapse
there was a couple of things that
happened in my life that um
were very shocking to me and um
i
i just and i wasn't going to meetings
and i you know it's the same old story
you know i was not connected to my
sobriety brothers and sisters and i was
drifting away and i um and something in
your mind it was just i just the pain
was too much so i did it and then so
what happened was
now two and a half months in three
months in i
i started coughing up
chunks of blood
right so i was because i've been a
smoker
since i was 17 years old right and i was
smoking so much weed and cigarettes i
would just cough up blood
but then simultaneously what happened
was
bob saget and louis anderson died
right and that week when i was coughing
up blood
and because of because i knew them both
of them
i
just in my head going i'm next because
to me everything happens in threes
yeah yeah and i'm like i'm and i had
convinced myself
that i was gonna die and that was on the
precipice of death
and so i
begged
my people to put me into this place in
arizona so
because i knew i knew what i needed to
go to a really rigorous psychology
program to get me out of wherever what i
was going through and also i was getting
at that time when i was
um in that hotel room i had not
drank or even smoked a cigarette or
didn't drug in a week i had to wait in
la for this bed to open up right
so i was coughing up blood i hadn't
slept and eaten right i was sober but
you know i was in so much pain
and i
slept naked by the door of this hotel
room because i thought it would be
easier for the maid to discover my body
i mean that's how [ __ ] up i was i
don't i was just in this
prison in my mind you know and um
i'm much better now
can you give some insights to how to get
out of that place how you got out of
that place
i think getting sober first of all was
very important but that still didn't do
it completely you know what i mean i
still was
convinced that i was
and then going i went to this place and
i did you know this place is a
12 hours a day psychotherapy place where
you do 12 hours of you see therapists
all day long
so it's it's like a
12 hour long podcast every day
yeah yeah but with professionals and
they call you on your [ __ ]
and they tell you what's real and they
tell you you know i mean you know i'm
going
also dealing with you know my still my
dad still some of these other things
that uh you know i mean and um
and the the third thing that
happened was when i got back to la after
that place
i i got my lungs checked out and i got
my um
physical done and you know ekg my heart
all of it and i was completely fine
you know and i quit smoking i haven't
been smoked in almost four months
been drank and didn't done drugs since
then too so um you know there's
definitely a complete clarity and i i
have to also admit that
this time around
it's just been completely different
is there still in the distance a fear of
relapse and all that kind of stuff is
that still no
so you feel good
i feel great yeah i feel better than
i've ever felt
even when hardship happens
yeah because it's like i no longer want
to be in that place yeah and also on top
of it it's like
it would be a real shame because i
worked so hard to get to this place in
my life not just in my career
with all of it you know i mean i have so
much to lose i have so many people that
love me
i just don't want
to be there again
you know let me ask you
sorry you've talked about this before
but it's interesting let me ask you a
question you always wear a suit only for
the podcast uh yeah i wore it in private
too oh you do not always know because i
get recognized that unfortunately so you
have to be selective about how i wear do
you like it when being recognized or no
uh so because of podcast as you probably
know uh the people that
at least recognize me are
happen to be amazing people so like yeah
like they
it's an immediate connection so there's
two things about that i don't like so
one i'm
i fall in love with people and so the
nature of interaction is like well it's
gonna be short
oh
so yeah yeah so like you have to say
goodbye
um
and i hate goodbyes you do yeah yeah and
then the other thing is just
introversion like i just i'm i'm an
introvert i'm a i have social anxiety i
have
um
nervous about talking to people and so
on so
so you have to always i'm walking around
always
a little bit anxious that there will be
an interaction but ultimately once it
starts it's fun it's it's beautiful and
then the the
the goodbye is what hurts so both the
hello and the goodbyes rehearse it's the
stuff in the middle of this delicious
i think this is a beautiful thing though
for people like you and i in a weird way
you know because um
number one
i'm i don't know about you but i'm an
isolator i don't really like you know
any kind of social thing you know um i
like my even when i was doing drugs and
drinking i never do with people i do it
privately in a garage you know
and secondly um
you know like i was my girlfriend and i
went watched the northmen the movie the
northmen
no what is it
does it tell me the plotline you didn't
even heard of the northmen i have not
heard of the northmen it's edgar's he
did uh
a movie called the witch he also did a
movie called the lighthouse you ever see
the lighthouse okay you watch movies
no you've never seen a movie uh i've
seen the godfather yeah i bet your money
you've seen dr zhivaga yes
you have yes yeah like you like
historical sweeping yeah schindler's
list yeah yeah yeah if it's not
historical or sweeping you know you're
not gonna all right so um
how do i explain it's it's basically a
viking movie
okay yeah yeah and um scar's one of the
scars guard i don't know the skarsgard
brothers is in it
bjork's in it willem dafoe nicole kidman
ethan hawk and it's a you know it's a
viking revenge movie so why does it make
you think about isolation no you could
know but what i was going to say is when
we went when we went to the movie
theater right um afterwards there was a
kid sitting next to me
and
um he just looks at me because he i
guess he didn't know i was sitting next
to him or whatever
and he just went you know
hey dude i just
can't believe you're sitting next to me
you know and
you're my hero
and um i'm think i'm doing comedy and
it's really hard so i was able to give
him some encouraging things and because
that's who i
am too you know i mean i i want to help
people
and i also um
you know
the idea that he likes me because he
also sped up specifics about my life
about
my comedy and this and that so he
definitely was a fan
and i was able to you know
you know i'm not even if i become
joe rogan famous or that big you know i
mean i've i'm always going to say hi to
people i'm always going to take photos
with people i i like that
part you know of me it makes me feel
also that i belong in a weird way
because i felt so invisible before i did
comedy
i mean i felt invisible and um
it puts me in the game of life i think
in a weird way you know so i think it's
good for you as well yeah it's a little
little moment of experiencing love
it's like it does feel like celebrating
life together you smile each other and
so on although you did say i think in a
recent podcast that
the you know people recognize you but
recognize you incorrectly
that i don't like that that's the
opposite of love okay
yeah that that i i don't like uh love
doing the hangover yeah i mean you know
i i you know i or this is what i don't
like this is why i hate this yes
some guy will like me right i'll take a
photo and then other people will go huh
he's somebody and will walk up to me and
go hey so why did he take a photo you
know i want a photo yeah and they're
like
no
i don't do would you do that no i would
i don't like that
no yeah yeah no but i do like the uh the
experience where maybe there's a couple
uh a guy and a girl boyfriend or
girlfriend and the guy
is the fan and the girlfriend has no
idea and it's always a funny interesting
oh yeah yeah yeah she's like trying to
figure out what is happening here yeah
and it's always beautiful to see but
what if the guy when he the guy explains
to to his girlfriend who you are do you
feel uncomfortable about that yeah yeah
it loads the information is transferred
quickly and she starts to understand
because she's not used to her boyfriend
being excited about a stranger yeah like
what what's happening here so it's a
fascinating little dynamic that's
beautiful it's like uh the spread of
information happens right there in real
life it's beautiful
it's mostly though do you would you say
that
it's probably usually men that recognize
you or
no but men the thing i've discovered is
men are more likely to approach
aggressively right
uh women recognize you they have a
different way of like double take
they don't want to uh invade your space
guys are like bro
yeah yeah they come in with a hug i had
uh
south by southwest i had a guy
um
i was just walking to a seven i go to
southern a lot my favorite spot gadget
7-eleven
uh sugar-free slushie i think okay for
happiness i like i find happiness at a
7-eleven so adorable late late at night
and he came up and you know what can i
tell you something that happened to me
and i haven't told anybody this never
happened to me before i was outside of a
7-eleven in austin i'm not going to say
which one and there was a gentleman
that approached me
this is at three or four at night which
is usually when i go uh a program all
night and i just like to go and take a
break
he approached me in the way that maybe
somebody who recognized me approached me
he did a double take he
walked past me and then walked back
and then looked at me and i went into
7-eleven i thought that's weird uh
and then i i came out with my slushie
and
and then
he approached me
and he said can i give you a [ __ ]
so i have never
[Laughter]
no really yeah so the energy i've never
had were you wearing a suit no okay i
was wearing like uh
the sweatpants and i was very kind of
like hiding from the world yeah yeah
type of thing i've never had anybody
approach me that way but the energy he
put the love he had in the approach
i thought he'd be like um
love you on rogan yeah i love you
something like love some kind of and
then he just said can i i'm forgetting
the exact wording because
it wasn't uh the the wording was such
that he wasn't
he wanted to make me happy ah he didn't
want to make himself happy you want to
make me happy well when i forgot can i
give you a [ __ ] i think that was the
thing it's like because if you said can
you give me a [ __ ] it would be it
would be very different yeah yeah yeah
no but
i think there's more aggressive way of
phrasing that but he he presented
himself yeah i forget because it was
almost like gentle and poetic and i was
like no
i i just started and said no no thank
you
that's what everyone does yeah no thank
you
probably started no no no no no no thank
you in my mind i was like is this a
threat
because it's fortnite ah i wasn't
exactly sure i mean i've never
experienced this i imagine this is what
sort of um women often experience that
kind of the danger the constant threats
all around you but i've never that's
just it was uh it was a funny little
moment i i didn't know what to do with
it
yeah that happened and i
i uh go to that 7-eleven often looking
for the guy
because now all right now i would say
yes no there you there used to be a
steam room in beverly on beverly
boulevard and um
my brother and i walked in there once
and i
we walked in and was a man sitting there
erection
and his dick was so big he was jerking
it off with both hands
and we kind of walked in and he goes
what's up and he just did it
and we just sat there you know i mean
because it was not aggressive
yeah yeah yeah maybe that was the same
feel you sensed that it wasn't an
aggressive thing yeah it wasn't yeah
yeah it was just a kind it was he was
just minding his own business he threw
it out
but it wasn't also
it wasn't sexual either it was like
it was like it's just you know it's just
like it's like love or something yeah
yeah i felt like he it's almost like can
i give you a hug
right then why don't you just take it i
i keep looking for it next time i see it
it's not in a gay world yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just want to be clear about that
you grew up in russia or ukraine
uh russia or russia yeah but your
great-grandmother my grandmother was in
my father's ukrainian oh you're my
grandmother's ukrainian so if you just
look at the full family trees about half
and half as russian a lot of conflict
with you right now
the internal yeah yeah yeah yeah let me
uh let me ask you've talked about this
before but
i'd love to sort of re-explore this as
carlos mencia
no my god yeah why
why go there again yeah
i'm willing to do it but
do you like carlos
well first of all i'm friends with joe
and i remember being a fan of i'm
outside this whole world i remember
thinking carlos was funny yeah so just
as a fan i was like oh funny and then uh
i remember this this all this big
controversy
uh about him stealing jokes
and
because i'm a fan of yours it's such an
interesting human dynamic and i'm a fan
of friendship and loyalty
and you had a great podcast conversation
with him it was tense it was so tense it
was very tense yeah but it was
interesting
and it it kind of what makes me think of
you talking to your father on that bunch
yeah that's essentially what it was um
some of it wasn't getting through but
maybe uh
how do you feel about that
uh whole thing about the guy i mean he
gave you he's a friend he gave you a lot
um
but you're you're also comedian so
stealing jokes is no good but also
there's like a
i don't know all the tensions in your
heart about all that whole thing how do
you feel about it
do you forgive him
okay let's just let's go back to
the it's very shakespearean in a very
weird way right because there's some
betrayal there you know i mean there's a
lot of drama when it comes to that
situation um
again also i'm a very loyal guy like
i've had the same manager
since um
in the late 90s and i've had every
gigantic manager want to sign me
even though my manager is great right
she's not a big company right and
there's only so much she can do
and maybe you know i mean my career
would have been different if i would
have signed with a bigger management i
don't know right but i will never leave
her
you know um i'll never leave my agent
matt you know
the people go well you're at caa that's
amazing the only reason why i'm at ca is
because of matt blake you know so there
are certain loyalties that i have the
comedy store
you know i mean i generally play the
comedy store mostly because my loyalties
are with them i don't know if that's a
good trait but it's just the way i am
right i admire that yeah okay so when it
comes to carlos
you know in the early
in the mid 90s is when i met him that
was a doorman at the la jolla comedy
store
he brought me on the road
he introduced me to matt like my agent
right and he
bought me a car
you know um when i couldn't pay rent
you know and i was really desperate i
could always go to him for money you
know and he helped me out in so many
different ways right so
in
you know i really appreciate that
paulie did the same thing um
so anyway um and then all of a sudden
and i always knew going on the road with
him that
number one i found it odd that he never
had a notebook
you know usually you know
comics riff with each other and they
write things down you know i mean me
i'll get together with people and write
you know i mean i'll do a new joke night
because i'm just too scared to try it in
front of a packed room or whatever it
might be okay
he never had did that right and he had
hours of material
and you know a lot of it was derivative
of other people's um
he would sometimes
hear a bit
change it to mexican like for instance
if uh you know if paul mooney had a joke
about black people he would change it
change it a bit but premise wise
it was always
extremely too similar and there are
examples on the internet so you know you
can there's things that you can't really
deny
and so when when that whole thing
happened um
you know it was like the titanic i mean
i was either gonna sync with carlos
or survive
and i did the worst not the worst thing
i i made a difficult decision and my
decision was to cut ties
and
you know over the years i've have felt
very guilty about it in in some respects
but um
you know there is always in my mind
i want to help him you know
i want to help him
reestablish some sort of
a different you know
route for him to go in terms of his
career and whatnot and so i had him on
my podcast
and it didn't go the way i wanted it to
go you know i mean i've always believed
if he just fully just
was apologetic and said you know i'm
sorry for stealing in general because we
don't know
specific i mean there's
specifics you know i mean
and i don't want to argue every case you
know so i thought the healthiest thing
to do was like in just in a broad way
listen
i stole i'm so sorry these are the
reasons why
and i'm a different guy now but it just
never happened in that way
and so it's been
difficult so you you don't think he
self-reflected looking in the mirror
about mistakes of the past at all like
do you think he's aware
i think it's ego
you know i think that he
for one reason or another he um
because there are probably jokes that he
legitimately in his heart know that he
wrote that people are accusing of
stealing right yeah but you know it's
like we don't know
right
so it's like
just apologize for all of it right but
he won't he fights for every
you know
every point and you know i just
think that that's not the route and he
i mean he's always gonna make money he's
you know he's never gonna be what he
should be
which is he's a powerful performer
you know
in terms of laughs
i mean dude i wouldn't i wouldn't want
to follow him he's a crusher
you know so it's like you know it's
really
he can act he has all the skill sets
it's just that
to me he went about it in the wrong way
and it's sad to me and uh but i still
always love him and i've always
will thank him for all the help that
he's done so you still got room in your
heart for him
i room for my heart for a lot of people
man you know hitler
all right what was uh returning back to
tiger belly because you said uh kalala
basically started it what's the origin
story of tiger belly
you know when i met her
oh by the way for people listening in
case you somehow don't know tiger belly
is a podcast you do it's an amazing
podcast you also do uh bad friends with
uh andrew centino yeah so on thank you
so much for the plug appreciate it i
don't know it's kante it's not the plug
can i plug other things though once
since we're doing it uh sure sure okay
that's your uh i'm on a show called okay
that's enough thank you so um
what what's the name of the show you're
on i want a couple a couple shows oh
it's good for you netflix it's no no
okay i'm on
sex in the city the sex in the city yeah
i'm on reservation
dogs it's an fx show
wait sex in the city is not a joke
no i am actually on sex in the city what
are they rebooting the show they did
okay it's called and just like that sex
in the city oh and you're on it yeah is
this not this is not a joke you can
google it okay
you know what i mean who do you play
i play
a podcaster on it on the show sarah
jessica parker's carrie
has a podcast and i'm her podcast
partner oh got it perfect but then but
i'm also now they've my storyline anyway
it's fine do you sleep with somebody on
there i am married on the show yeah they
showed my i married to a young lady on
it yeah
it felt like it felt like it you know
because you don't think doing it
i look around going are you sure i'm
supposed to be on this
you know i mean i do feel that but
lo and behold i'm on it yeah you are
so um i started this way so you know my
friend david cho
do you know him he's an artist
he used to have a podcast right
called dvd asa
and um
he used to have me on it and then kalila
started doing it
and then when dvdsa ended
kalila was just like let's start our own
and i was like nah it's not gonna work
so she goes well fine i'm gonna just do
it on my own then
so she went and bought the equipment
and we were living in a condo at the
time in hollywood and she um
would do them on her own
she did probably three on her own
and one day i was watching television
the door was open to the podcast room
and
i looked turned around and she was
literally like this did she we had a
table like this with she had the mic and
all that stuff and she was doing this
she was like slumped over
like this
and i just kind of went [ __ ] it
so i walked in there and go all right
let's just do one yeah
and that was that's how it started and
then chemistry was there immediately
well i already knew that she could do it
because of dvdsa right so i already knew
that she had the skill set it's you know
you know it's just all about even in
this conversation that you and i had
today right there are gaps of like oh
what else should we talk about right
yeah right or like i don't know what
direction right and it's all about the
old improv rule
adding information
even if you don't know what you're going
to say just fill the dead space with
something
like so right now if we had some stuff
we stopped talking about something like
like when i asked you did you grew up in
russia or ukraine right was one of those
dead spaces where i was just like let's
just throw it out there see where this
goes right
and she has that ability to fill that
dead space with information that's all
you need right
and um she gets it in that way so it's
like when we um
you know started doing it
at dvdsa i just knew that she had the
skill set so when we started doing it
for tiger belly
it was a given you know you know she can
do it i've had girlfriends that wouldn't
be able to do it what what are you doing
you know you have the skill set
you know you're a sciency guy you spend
all night long you know i mean
you know i mean
you know doing whatever you're [ __ ]
doing right but you have this innate
ability to do it
right and i think it's a talent
do you think it's a talent
no do you think it's do you think you
have talent
what are you doing
i know what you're doing not adding
information i know what you're doing
that's a good pit it's a good thing i
kept doing it and you kept filling the
space it's quite interesting yeah that
is true huh because you're yes ending
yourself which is great the improv thing
that's really impressive can i ask you a
question sure have you ever had a guest
on
that didn't add information and then you
had to keep doing it
yeah yeah
but it's part of the magic too and
sometimes i feel like uh
they were actually giving me a gift of
silence
and i was stepping on it like for
example i had a conversation with jocko
you know jocko willink
and every question i would ask him in
the beginning and i'm now better friends
with him
it was the first time we met in that
conversation and i would ask him these
long questions of mumble and meander and
so on and he would answer with yes or no
and that's it yeah
and then but he'd do it in a strong like
viking-like way
and i kept i kept
uh trying to
go full like
uh bobby lee style of create chaos and
just keep talking talking and so on
as opposed to i think he was inviting me
more for the stoic type of
silence short sentences that kind of
conversation so i [ __ ] that up i
believe uh but yeah there's uh
that not the adding information part but
the adding chemistry part
where something it's usually ego
where
where people don't realize there's a
magic to be found between two humans
like genuine it's like a first date like
that to truly listen to each other and
to do the yes and thing
and have fun with it
uh when you have this energy i'm way too
important
for this conversation
that the yeah the information might be
there but the chemistry is not so you
have to remember that a lot of the
podcasts i've done are
like technical yeah and so
you could still say a lot of stuff about
like what what the this project or
whether it's physics or robotics or
biology you could say informational
stuff but the the excitement the magic
is not there
but i often blame myself because like if
i'm excited
they'll be excited i've learned this so
i'm learning i'm not allowed to have
like a
uh bored face which
mine my face is naturally looks bored
but on the inside i'm excited yeah it's
a it might be a russian thing i don't
know it's not can i tell you why you're
not boring your face all right
because um you have crow's feet
oh this thing yeah
yeah and the reason why you have crow's
feet
is you smile a lot
yeah yeah you're very expressive i know
white dudes i don't trust white dudes
yeah right with no crow's feet
right because that means they don't that
they're not you know me accessing that
part of their you know i mean face yeah
you know which is why i hate when um
this is an la thing especially yeah uh
women have talked to me but like botox
and they they hate the crow they they
hate not not me on themselves oh and
they they hate because it's all wrinkles
and stuff like that and to me it's like
no that's where the that's the magic the
magic it really is yeah
uh so okay so the interesting thing
about tiger belly
is there's some weird like aesthetic to
it it's really unique it's not just good
it's also unique like in the way that
wes anderson films are unique like life
aquatic i don't know if you know those
films yeah i love those i mean they're
my favorite films yeah what is that what
is that
it it's not just the chemistry between
you and koala it's like
what is that can you can you put a
finger on it or is it just like
well it's it's essentially who i am i
like i
that's what my all my houses have looked
like that
you know i mean like i've always been a
collector of
designer toys you know i mean i've
always been a collector of um kind of
weird artwork
um
yeah i've always been like that you know
i i like weird wallpaper like i'll get
instead of like going to a wallpaper
store what i'll do is i'll get artwork
that i like from an artist like and go
get the you know get their approval
and go to a place and make wallpaper out
of their artwork
you know what i mean you can like if i
wanted a lex friedman your face on my
wall i would ask for your permission and
i would probably put your face on a
gigantic wall like i would do stuff like
that that's awesome yeah but
can you do that yeah
you have my permission you know i think
i will yeah you know i think i will go
for the laugh yeah yeah i mean but i
would do it big please yeah yeah yeah
yeah but my point is is that i um
yeah it's essentially who i am on the
inside i guess in terms of like my
you know
i don't know but i don't really i've
never
i'm glad you said that because i never
even
thought about that
yeah he's just you know you just kind of
do it like this you know because all
your podcasts have this black
ominous thing yep you're you know you're
wearing a black suit
you have a specific thing too it's like
but i don't i don't really think people
ask me like why do you wear a suit i
really don't i just feel good in it yeah
just who i am and the reason why my
podcast looks the way i do is because i
feel comfortable in that environment and
it you know
like you
i don't try to think too much about
what i'm doing on tiger belly or even
bad friends right because when you start
thinking about it and go we should do
this segment and i should you know
do it this way or this podcast does it
this way so what you know
no i just show up i keep my mind open
and i do the best i can i add
information like we talked about and i
just keep talking right and i'm being i
try to be authentically myself
like right now you know i had this fear
when i was i was f
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] bathroom man yeah
because i was so scared out of fear
yeah yeah and like you know i was like
kind of nervous because i
you know this whole week and it wasn't
anticipating coming here and i watched
the mark normand one i watched the
giannis one to see you know how
tonally and last night my girlfriend
just looked at me just goes
just show up
yeah carla knows
who i am
dude you think that
first of all
let me ask you something yes you think i
have the day you know how busy i'm to
drive all the way over here to west
hollywood yeah to do your [ __ ] thing
why would i do that
yeah because we are a well aware of who
you are and we like you
thank you god we want you on ours yeah i
would love that i would love that as a i
mean that's that's that's the reason i'm
doing this is just to get in your pocket
you gotta get on it awesome
uh
yeah it's funny because i just mentioned
to you uh offline i got a chance to talk
to oliver stone
and he asked me this thing which is you
know how many um listeners does this
thing get all that kind of stuff and i
don't even pay attention to that
so it's like i just don't
a little bit though you do don't
i wrote extensions on my browsers where
i don't see the views the number of
views really yeah don't pay did you know
that like some of your youtube videos on
interviews and stuff have over a million
that i know i know i know like loosely
that
like it bleeds through but it's it's not
part of my conscious like
um
thing i think about i'm very
i've just seen it destroy people's minds
where they're no longer thinking
creatively they're not
they don't feel good if something they
do doesn't get as much attention as they
thought it should it just can destroy
you
even though it's good it could be great
stuff you create that nobody everybody
ignores
but it was still great it is it is still
great
and uh sort of
letting that negatively affect your mind
is a i don't know i've seen it destroy
people so i'm very nervous about that
it's like that old saying
never living the results
it's like if i
if i podcast to make i'd like initially
honestly
when i did tiger belly we made no money
for the first
couple of years oh let me like bare like
not enough to put a dent i couldn't buy
anything like you know nice or anything
um it was um side money you know i mean
i could buy some shoes once a month or
whatever right
and
like i said before um
i was my career was in the [ __ ] right
so
tiger billy wasn't like this is going to
be the thing
you know i mean it was just something to
do with my girlfriend creatively you
know
and it just so happens
that it did do all these things for me
right um podcasting but um
yeah i never and still today i don't do
it for any of those things you know i do
it because um
it's fun
yeah yeah it is right yeah yeah uh let
me ask you since you say why you love
kalila why do you love slash hey george
george kimmel your uh producer
what's your favorite thing about him
let's say that
positive thing positive
because you know it's like
you know i don't want to give them
compliments but you know i'll try yeah
yeah i'll try um
have you actually i i don't think you've
publicly ever
i
said
think i have either so i i'm gonna get
i'm gonna give it a go i'm gonna give it
a real go here okay yeah
you know at the end of the day when it
comes to
money when it comes to responsibility
you know obviously this is a business
now
for you and me it is you know it's it's
a side business but it's a business
and um
you want to be able to trust the people
that are running it and i have 100
trust in everything that he does in
terms of financial things in terms of
technical things in terms of
all of it you know i mean merchandise
and
i have 100
um belief in him i
and that's rare you know to find someone
like that um
also
at the end of the day i know his heart
and he really is
a great guy he there's nothing about him
like for instance
you know he was over the other day and i
go you know i bought this keith wooden
thing that some native man made
and i don't know how to put it on the
wall
so i just you know i go hey can you
figure this out and he goes yeah i got
it you know i mean like he's just that
guy yeah you know um
he's also but
but there is a part of me and this is
probably wrong yeah
but there's a part of me that feels like
i kind of made him
yeah he would be nothing with that no
that's not what i'm saying why i just
[ __ ] said that's the way i heard it i
did that's what i meant okay
but that's not what you said
it's probably wrong right because he did
all the things that he has in his life
he did on his own right right but still
for some reason he'd be nothing without
you
is that what i'm saying but that's what
i mean yeah okay yeah so basically like
because when i
met him i was a part of this
um youtube studio called maker studios
and he was just a producer there and
that's how i met him and when he left
maker he came to us and he wasn't a
podcast producer and now he has this big
company he produces a bunch of podcasts
you know and he has a bunch of employees
and he has a nice business you know and
i feel like i had a lot to do with it so
both the confidence and the good heart
yeah what about gilbert
yeah gilbert is a godsend as well you
know i i don't know if you because of
let me ask you this because you're a
science guy
this is an interesting question for me
um
do you believe
just the universe gives you
certain things
at the right moment at the right time do
you believe that there is a mechanism
out there
where it's just we're just a part of
this machine that's kind of like
almost as if things are just happening
the way it's supposed to happen or do
you think this is these random
things that are hap occurring and we're
just it's chaos in that way i don't know
from a science perspective because i
wouldn't be able to explain it but i do
believe you mentioned karma there's
there's a karma thing
it just
if you put love out there in the world
like certain doors open in a certain
kind of way
like they're almost waiting for you and
then you walk to them so yes in that way
i believe
that it just it feels like um
not everything is like a basic like
billiard ball model of like
you have to fight for everything you
could just generally be cool to people
and kind to people and certain
opportunities just pop up
at the right moment more specifically
though you know so for instance
let's suppose like gilbert for instance
he just showed up at my house one day i
didn't know who he was i had a fight
night and a friend brought him right
this is right when
kaleila and i were starting tiger ballet
right and in conversation he was like we
didn't know how to
engineer
we didn't have an engineer for our
podcast and that night he was that you
know i know how to do it
right
and if i hadn't met him that night he
just wouldn't i don't know if it would
be as good it would be completely
different and i really believe that we
were
we met him that night for a reason you
know so you don't believe that
it's complicated i believe that for love
and these kinds of things but i don't
believe that as much for
building a team but that's the
engineering thing i think that's the
the artist in you
i'm less of an artist i think artists
thrive
in the chaos of it so it's not only that
you guys met at that time
is you didn't probably ask in detail
about his qualifications or didn't
didn't go through a rigorous thing you
just dove in and figure it out on the
fly i think
that's that's sort of the artist ethic i
think with like if you're doing a
startup or engineering there's a little
bit more rigor in in the selection
process
because the same with with rogan jamie
just walked up to him
uh
jamie vernon yeah yeah yeah yeah he just
walked up to the same kind of situation
and they made it you know uh both both
of you have one of the best podcasts in
the world and so it's like
how did that
what
yeah i i i believe it's very strange
it's strange yeah maybe it's just like
cool people hang out with cool people so
you kind of collide that's not true
because they're because
that's not true because with bad friends
for instance right
um
i've had 12 people before andrew santino
that had asked me to do one with me
right
and
you know they just was it wasn't
didn't want to do it yeah you know um
with andrew though it happened kind of
organically and in in in a way that was
almost like
in my heart meant to happen
in a weird way that's a weird
combination by the way so why did why
was that the sticky one
because you have a lot of comedian
friends why andrew because number one
we both know
just instinctually without even talking
about it that in many ways we're polar
opposites in terms of like energy right
he's more aggressive i also know i
respond good with alpha males
you know i mean because i'm more of a
follower you know i mean or sensitive in
that way but in in many ways i am an
alpha male in certain areas of my life
you know yeah well you know when it
comes to smashing dog what's up you know
maybe yeah but you know so we both knew
instinctually that that in that way our
chemistry worked right and also in terms
of style and all that stuff is
completely just
it was just an organic given
to us
yeah yeah
but
you trust yourself with power
you play dictators
would it be do i
like because i feel like you would be
because you said you're not an alpha
male but in many ways
um when you smash what's up and you
winked at me
would you uh
what do you think about that
if i give you absolute power would you
be able to uh what would you
change what does absolute power mean
like you said to me listen you are going
to be the dictator of planet earth and
anything that you want is at your means
including violence sex no
i would not
because even in my personal life now
there are things that i could do
right that i have power i guess
that i don't participate in right so why
would i do it if i had ultimate power
i mean because there's always there's
still a moral and ethics that i have
right that i don't feel
comfortable with right so you wouldn't
even enjoy it
no i mean i think that um there would be
no if i had ultimate dictatorship on
planet earth there would be no violence
i mean i would not cause any wars right
but if there's an uprising yeah i'd have
to quell it that's how it starts bobby
you quell it don't don't surprise
right but so first you're gonna
censor everybody who wants to even
suggest the idea of uprising and then
and then one person gets out of line
they run a red light okay
that's that's but
you ever get angry in traffic
yeah
i get rageful so if you could murder
that person no
no no no
nobody has to know
no i would give them cancer
but i would have not so much
[Laughter]
okay no but no here no this is an
interesting thing because i want i want
to elaborate all right so
the thing if i was the dictator of the
planet earth right um
there would be a reason why people would
uprise right so give me a reason
because i would give them food shelter
right and all the things i feel like
that people would desire right
but you're right but you're right
because they're you're right i think
this is what you're talking about yeah
so here's the deal so there are certain
things that i do believe in right like
for instance it's a very controversial
thing right
in terms of a woman's right
right in terms of abortion right i feel
like as a male
i
it's not my body so i don't really even
have an opinion and i shouldn't even
have a voice on it because you know i
mean a woman like it's like if they
created laws if white people men created
laws for koreans
in america like you don't have the right
to
right so it's like so if i would just if
i was a dictator right i would just be
like yeah women have ever all the rights
in the world right and they you know and
i think
abortion should be legal throughout the
planet earth right but there will be
people out there that will believe that
no
you know what i mean
we you know
we're pro-life so you would put them in
jail just so that's right so i think as
a dictator you there was no way to be
able to please everyone so there will be
an uprising yeah so yeah [ __ ] it i don't
want to do it okay would you do it
uh
not
no there's several loaded questions
would i enjoy it
no
would i
uh do it no because i don't trust my own
mind under power like i'm well aware
that
uh in situations where i have control
it's it's
as much of freedom as it is a burden
like it can change you i'm very nervous
about that
interesting like how much uh
uh how much the ego starts to flare up
how much
just like the
less
uh pleasant things about your nature
come up you know i have a temper too
like i have all that kind of stuff
and uh you have i'm sure you have a bit
of a temper yeah yeah i have a temper
yeah and so whenever nobody is able to
as clearly call you out on your [ __ ]
that's that could be a problem
do you have this when you you when you
rage out and you have a temper is there
like
like either a day later or a couple
hours later is there shame and regret
that comes along with that or no
yeah no no of course yeah during it yeah
during it too yeah shame and regret yeah
yeah and then but i try to make sure
it's like love and respect are felt
always underneath the whole thing
um
but still it's like human emotion you
can't control it
and if you give an absolute power you
start to lose your sense of the world
you start to be unable to see what is
right and wrong you think everybody
everything is right
you start to be
um have a distorted view of who is doing
the wrong things in the world and then
also distrust
well that has to do more with how
absolute power is easily attained
because when you're in the seat of power
everybody first on the outside but then
in your inner circle you start to
distrust them you start to believe that
they're going to
they want your power so the people you
love the people that were source of so
much
beauty for you previously uh like even
like
your girlfriend wife
your closest lifelong friends you start
to suspect them i don't want to live
like that yeah yeah yeah and you're
often right to suspect them
so because you think they change a
little bit too they change too yeah they
start a little bit taste of that power
yeah it was the interesting thing is a
bunch of people in the in hitler's inner
circle at the very end betrayed him too
in in search of their own power
wow it's fascinating it's fascinating
this power thing uh let me ask you a
bunch of ridiculous questions real quick
okay
if you can be someone else for a day
someone alive today who you haven't yet
met who would you be for one day you get
to be it could be female male that'd be
like i always wanted to see what a pop
star was like which one would you like
harry styles
okay yeah yeah so if i'm harry styles
right
i just want to see like
what it'd like to go to the beverly
center okay that's harry styles
hairstyle yeah or coachella just walk
around coachella as harry styles
you know i mean we get a lot of
attention and it's a very specific kind
of attention yeah i just want to see
what that's like i want to be able to
because the thing is is that i want to
be able to like see what it's like
um in terms of how easy would it be
to get a hot chick
oh
i thought you meant to like get a table
at a restaurant no no no that you know i
can still do now as bobby lee you know
but as harry styles or i want to see
what it'd be like and how that would go
about like how easy it would be you know
what i mean yeah yeah uh okay like could
you just walk up to the hottest chick at
coachella and start making out with them
but yeah that's interesting just to see
just to see
yeah yeah because i know as bobby lee no
no no no
could you no you couldn't do that no no
that's an interesting reason
so if you were the last person on earth
like everybody disappeared everybody's
dead
uh
what would your day look like what would
your days look like what would you do
that's interesting because if i was able
to figure out the you know
electricity
right i think my days would be like why
didn't you learn about electricity oh
yeah right you realize how little you
know yeah yeah why didn't you learn
about these things because now you're
gonna die yeah right yeah but i think
the first thing obviously is
now let me ask you something why
now if you're saying that um i'm the
last person on planet earth because
there was an alien invasion and there's
predators and things that i have to
[ __ ] look out for that's one way but
if i'm just all of a sudden i wake up
and just everyone's gone
and everyone's dead everyone's dead but
there's no threat there's no threat then
what i would do is i go
well let's find
a place to live not probably my house
right so i probably live in a place
where that's closest to
grocery stores
right so i would get food and stuff
first right and then secondly it's like
you know i'll probably go you know what
i've thought about i would probably go
to um san marcos
san diego vista because that's where the
real doll factory is they just [ __ ] all
of them no no i would have to grab like
six of them because i'm gonna get lonely
six of them for a variety you wouldn't
be monogamous with one doll no no and i
also would carry out like the the you
know the vagina parts right you know and
all the accessories and stuff right yeah
and then go back to la probably oh man
why would i stay down there you could
stay in the factory no yeah maybe it's
that factory and then um but i think
thirdly i would run out of electricity
right and i think you know i mean my
demise would come slow well you could
find sources of electricity because
nobody's using it
so i don't know how to turn the machines
on like i don't know how to go to the
[ __ ] um
yeah
what do you what do you call it the
place where it's i don't even know what
it's called
the place where you don't mean where it
all
the energy is generated yeah the
generators like where do i go yeah
it's a good question okay all right
would you rather lose all your old
memories or never be able to make new
ones
the past or the future
no i mean i can't lose my memories
all of them that makes me who i am but
you wouldn't be able to make new ones
you wouldn't be so you'd be living in
the moment non-stop with all the
all the
but you did say you're in a really good
place
so maybe this is a pretty good set of
memories you got you got all that
yeah
i mean you just
that's a nightmare
you just created a nightmare for me
that's a nightmare the choice the choice
is a nightmare yeah
you're [ __ ] either way
it's already beautiful it's a kind of
death
not being able to make new memories
that's it that's all you got yeah you
get to relive the memories you have
as a science guy let me ask you a
question sure
are you afraid to die
yeah of course i'm i'm not of course i
am i think about it every day
yeah i yeah i meditate on my on my
mortality all the time right it doesn't
make any sense it's terrifying it's
terrifying and because
are you terrified because of the unknown
or because you believe
it's nothingness
the unknown but my best guess is that
it's something like nothingness and that
nothingness is so terrifying yeah the
infinity of the nothingness yeah yeah
but ram das says and this is something
that i always you know ramdas yeah
ramdas says
he believes that death
is like removing
a tight shoe
like release
like ah
that could be it too i think maybe when
we die
that's initially maybe the last feeling
that we have
is release
and then if that happens and there's
nothingness i think that's cool
well no that that has to do more with
the actual feeling of death which i
think some people are afraid of the
experience to make sure it's
it's a it's a
it's one of
release like you said yeah but the
existential aspect that you no longer
exist
like all the [ __ ] you're doing kind of
as soon as you'll live forever
right like you don't really con like all
the your career and all that kind of
stuff you probably will be forgotten i
know
like completely
erased yeah so all you have is a few
moments in this life a few moments of
joy a few moments of trauma
of suffering and that's it i know but
here's the and you're wasting your time
today talking to me and then you have
you have a few such moments you'll do a
couple hundred more podcasts
and then you'll be dead
no because this right here dude right
is
human
number one
i walked through a little fear today so
i learned some things right
i'm talking to a science guy which i
never thought i could you're the first
scientist i've ever talked to yeah right
you get a diploma at the end of this oh
good and there's i i believe that there
was a connection
right not in the gateway not a gateway
non-gay
connection right um
in certain circumstances i probably
would blow you
would you in a certain circumstances
like if we were the last two people on
planet earth and stuff like that sure
yeah yeah but yeah those are probably
the only ones but uh or like somebody
put a gun to my eyes you gotta blow lex
okay then yeah that's kind of all right
yeah yeah i'm turned on right now
yeah
let me ask you one
one question go ahead what do you think
is the meaning of life
my [ __ ] that's the last one yes this
is the last one yeah what do you think
why are we here
why are you here why are we here does
any of it make sense i i think
ultimately
here's the what's why i like life in
general
is what we talked about like we view
death
there is a mystery there
there's a wonderment to it right so it's
like when i walk outside you know and i
look at the trees and i look at
buildings that man made these buildings
and you know i look at the universe and
i look in the sky and i don't really
completely comprehend what's going on
right it's just so in i'm in awe of all
of it right
and i don't have any answers right but
that i think is what the meaning of life
is is to be in awe of it and
the wonder of it all
and
it's just amazing yeah just open your
eyes to the wonder of it yeah
while we're still here yeah bobby uh
it's a huge honor to finally meet you
i've been a fan for many many years
um it's an honor that you would even
consider blowing me in the correct kind
of circumstances i think you would blow
me in the right circumstances i think
that's the definition of love
bobby thanks so much thanks thank you so
much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with bobby lee to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from kurt
vonnegut
laughter and tears are both responses to
frustration and exhaustion
i myself prefer to laugh
since there's less cleaning to do
afterward
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time